hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on fortnight again and
today we're gonna be doing a guide on
how to use the remote explosives device
how to guide how to use it effectively
all that type of stuff so let's get
started so like I said we're going to go
over what the item or weapon is the
damage stats how to be most effective
with it and then if it's worth using by
comparing it to similar items or weapons
that do around the same thing simply put
this is a c-4 explosives device that has
four charges when picked up and you can
carry a maximum of ten and they can be
found in chests supply llamas flora loot
and supply drops they can be found
anywhere you can place the charges with
right trigger on Xbox left mouse button
on PC and r2 on ps4 and the detonator
button is the opposite that being right
mouse button on PC left trigger on Xbox
or l2 on ps4 you place down as many as
you want and blow them all at the same
time you don't have to go one by one
each individually but the charges must
light up blue and stick to the floor or
surface before they can explode this
isn't like call of duty black ops 2
where you could detonate these things in
midair there must be stationery to
explode these can also be blown up by
shooting them with any weapon when asked
a few questions about the remote
explosives device one of the developer
said and I'll put the image on the
screen says you can only detonate your
own explosives but you can shoot ones
enemies have placed you place as many as
you can find it but they explode in the
order you placed them in so if there's a
chance that you have about 15 of them
you will you they will all blow up but
in the order you placed and there is no
detonation range meaning you could be on
the other end of Tilted towers and still
blow up the charges sadly though the
developer did say that you cannot stick
these two teammates or enemies that
would have been really nice to do some
funny moments with that but that is a no
you cannot stick them to teammates or
enemies the rarity is rare or blue and
that is the only type of rarity in the
game so far for the damage this thing
does 72 an opponent I tested this out on
myself and an opposing player and they
all did the same damage stacking four of
these together would use 280 damage
which is absolutely incredible the only
issue with this is that they have to be
really really close to the explosive
device and the four of these obviously
have to be really close to get that 280
damage and these obviously take a lot of
time to place and then explode so it is
very unlikely that you'll actually get
all four of these to blow up on
single person unless they're sitting
still the remote explosives device also
does a lot of damage to walls in the one
clip I ended up blowing up a brick wall
which has 300 HP and one hit and I also
managed to blow up a metal wall which
has 400 HP as well with one charge so
this can definitely do lots of damage to
bases you want to be using the remote
explosives device in a few certain
scenarios or situations which are
defense or base attacking when in a
building you can place these around the
inside preferably near doors to catch
unaware players if they walk by it if
you're in a base that you can put them
you put them around your base kind of
like tripmines and either blow them up
or shoot them when an enemy gets close
to you in a clip that I made possibly
will show I was near Factory and there
was a guy who had about 7 charges and he
kept putting him around the factory and
I could not enter and he kept blowing
them up trying to figure out where I was
another good tactic as well as if you're
kind of confused on what floor or what
level it is other person happens to be a
maybe your gray building or HQ one
tilted or any other building with
multiple floors just start throwing
charges and start chucking through the
wall and stuff and then you can easily
take care of the whole house leaving the
person exposed so that you can find them
and kill them the next situation would
be based attacking since the explosive
does lots of damage like we stated this
does one shot to every single type of
material you can knock out a person's
base with one charge depending on the
size or material they use it may take a
couple charges like I said if they have
a pretty big base you might have to do a
couple to blow up the entire thing this
works super well in teamfights is you
could blow up the opponent's base while
your teammate draws their fire or
distracts them then the base will be
destroyed leaving them that team exposed
with no cover if you're playing solo you
can either get to the high ground and
Rane c4 on top of them or sneak into
their base if they're preoccupied and
not looking and then blow the bottom of
their base out I personally believe that
you definitely don't want to use these
remote explosives when you're up close
or far away in the clip I showed I
followed a guy drunk junction and I all
I had was a remote explosive so I
decided to charge him with it this was
the first time I'd ever had the remote
explosives in my hand so I didn't
realize that they weren't exactly the
greatest in close quarters combat that
didn't go well obviously seeing in the
clip that I ended up dying although I
was very close to killing him I believe
I left him with about 30 HP it doesn't
matter because
I died and he didn't if the remote
explosives devices and all the c4 could
explode wall twist in the air and it
didn't have to be flat on the floor then
this tactic might be a little bit more
useful and you can get a little bit more
aggressive with this type of weapon the
obvious reason for not using it far away
is that it can't reach that far
unlike the common grenades these
explosives don't go that far so just
stick the base is strong for this weapon
quick tip for this is that always you
you always want to have a shotgun at the
ready because since it's mainly used for
base destroying you're going to be in
close quarters combat with the team or a
opposing player if you're in the solo
game-mode you're gonna be destroying his
base he's then they're going to be
falling from their base with either no
damaged health or maybe some damaged
cells obviously depending on how high
their base was so I have a shotgun out
ready to either one pump them or finish
them with the TAC shotgun and then grab
the loop and then lastly to end the
video we have a comparison and then just
my thoughts overall just the general
simplified thoughts about the weapon
compared to the weapons like the RPG and
grenade launcher which also have
explosive damage the RPG and the grenade
launcher are way better choices both do
more damage and have longer ranges than
the remote explosives compared to the
regular common grenades it's a bit
different if your intent is to blow up a
player then just use the grenades
especially if the enemy's far away since
you can chuck those guys for miles if
you're trying to destroy a base then
just stick with the remote explosives
because as we previously mentioned can
one-shot all the materials in fortnight
I personally don't think you're going to
be seeing this a lot in solo play
obviously since the weapon had just
released a lot of people are going to be
picking it up and starting to figure out
how to use it maybe what's best solo I
personally think is not going to be the
right direction for this only because
with the 5 loadout spots we have you're
definitely going to have an AR probably
a scar pumper attack or maybe both
doesn't matter you're gonna have one or
two healing items leaving about one item
roughly for sniper rocket launcher I
don't know what your type of loadout is
but I like to rock the assault rifle
shotgun and then either sniper a rocket
launcher with two medicals whether that
be bandages and a Medicaid or shield or
something like that
so I don't have enough room for the
remote explosive especially as we talked
about before at the grenade launcher and
the RPG are way better choices for
destroying bases than the remote
explosives are due to the more damage
and the longer range it has I do however
see this being utilized in squads a lot
only because obviously there's going to
be four players with five different
loadouts that's going to be 20 spaces so
not every single person on the team is
going to have a full inventory that
means that one guy that maybe has one or
two spots open can pick up the explosive
devices charge their baseball like I
said previously with that one tip charge
the base and then have his opponent and
then have his teammates distract the
opponent's blows up the base throw out a
cover and it's gg for them but those are
my thoughts in it let me guys know what
you guys think about the remote
explosive devices and if you have any
more tips or anything that you found
useful leave them in the comments below
for other people to enjoy just in case I
forgot to mention one step so that
everyone can be well up acquainted with
the remote explosive device and that
boys is going to be the end of the video
hopefully you guys did enjoy this guide
I'm gonna start doing a lot more guides
on these new weapons obviously because
Ford Knight likes to be updated roughly
weekly with new types of items
hopefully the jetpack will come soon
stink bomb which we talked about last
week in any of these new items that got
leaked and the data files I'll likely do
guides on those when they release
because these are a lot of fun to do and
I like talking about this type of stuff
so if that pleases you or not and you
want to see more guides for me
definitely hit the like button and
subscribe like I said if you want to
watch more of my fortnight content my
two most recent video is gonna be on
screen subscribe if you're new I'm gonna
be I'm gonna start covering guides how
to's for fortnight make everybody a
better player especially with these
guides on weapons you know the remote
explosive device any new weapons that
are coming in the future any new points
of interest whether there'd be a new
area a whole new map anything like that
I'll likely be covering on how to get
better with it like I mentioned most
recent videos gonna be on screen if you
guys do want to check those out with
that guys hope you have a great rest
your day and peace out